who are you wearing you look incredible
dolce gabbana
[Music]
yeah
um did we zendaya was there tonight have
we seen her have you guys gotten to him
i haven't seen her yet but i hope i hope
to see her soon
um it's a big night how does it feel to
be at vanity fair's oscars party
fantastic we out here you feel me have
you seen the viral video of someone who
was like oh my god
you were their waiter at their birthday
brunch years ago in brooklyn and now
they have this video
[Music]
i was a lot of people's you filming bus
boy waiter server
you feel me in all shapes and forms what
would you tell yourself then like
knowing what you know now that you're
here you've made at your vanity fair
i'll be like
damn what you doing over there man
that's wild
yeah well what do you tell
it
what do you tell the fans who had such
incredibly emotional strong reactions to
the finale
um
i'll tell them uh
that's what's up you know what i'm
saying what was your reaction when you
first read the script
i mean
what what part of the script
the the final episodes
oh yeah i was uh
i was i was kind of tripping i'm like oh
yeah that's that's wild
where do you hope the show goes from
here
uh i hope it keeps going up
has it been all been emotional for you
yeah yeah well you look awesome go have
fun tonight anybody you're excited to
see
uh everybody i'm excited to see
everybody i love everybody you feel me
so and what's next for
i don't you
take some pictures and whatnot
i don't know maybe talk to somebody else
i don't know
do we really have to wait till 2024 for
season three oh no
you know oh
yeah
they don't know they don't tell me
give us one word for what's going to
happen in season three
[Music]
you